>> Lawrence: AS YOU CAN ALREADY
SEE CRIME IN AMERICA IS ON THE
RISE AND AMERICANS ARE GETTING
WORRIED.
WE HAVE BRAND NEW POLL NUMBERS
FROM FOX NEWS.
70% PEOPLE FEEL THERE IS MORE
CRIME IN THE COUNTRY NOW
COMPARED TO 2020.
WITH 54% SAYING CRIME HAS GONE
UP IN THEIR OWN LOCAL AREA.
IT'S GETTING SO BAD EVEN SOME
LIBERALS ARE CONCERNED THAT
MAYBE THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
SO QUICK TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
JOINING ME NOW THE GREAT DAN
BONGINO.
HOST OF THE DAN BONGINO SHOW
STREAMING WEEKDAYS ON FOX NATION
12:00 TO 3:00.
DAN, I HAVE BEEN GOT TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU.
YES, IT IS TRUE THAT THEY WANT
TO DEFUND THE DEFUNDED THE
POLICE, CRIME WAS ALREADY GOING
UP IN THESE LIBERAL CITIES
BEFORE THAT WHEN THEY DEFUNDED
THE POLICE.
THEY ONLY EXASPERATED THE
PROBLEM, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
I THINK THE BIG QUESTION HERE,
YOU ARE NOT WRONG.
CERTAIN CRIMES WERE GOING UP.
SHOOTINGS AND HOMICIDES WERE
GOING UP.
BUT ONCE WE HAD -- WE SAW
LOCKDOWNS.
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THE
LOCKDOWNS IS YOU SAW STREET
ROBBERIES AND OTHER THINGS GO
DOWN BECAUSE THERE WAS WAS
NOBODY ON THE STREET.
WHICH MAKES THE INCREASE IN
SHOOTING AND HOMICIDES EVEN MORE
UNBELIEVABLE WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IT.
RIGHT?
BUT THE REAL QUESTION HERE IS
WHY?
WHY -- WHAT'S BEHIND THIS?
WHY DO LIBERALS LIVE IN AN
ALTERNATE REALITY?
IT'S A SERIOUS QUESTION.
I KNOW LIBERAL OH MY GOSH WHY
ARE YOU ALWAYS YELLING AT US ALL
THE TIME?
BECAUSE YOU LIVE IN A PLANET NO
ONE ELSE LIVES ON.
YOU LIVE ON A PLANET WHERE
TAKING MONEY AWAY FROM THE
POLICE, FIRING POLICE OFFICERS,
ATTACKING POLICE OFFICERS, AND
MAKING THEM THE OBJECT OF YOUR
SCORN SOMEHOW LEADS TO BETTER
PUBLIC SAFETY.
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW NO SANE
PERSON LIVES IN THAT WORLD.
BUT YOU DO.
AND THE QUESTION, LAWRENCE IS
WHY?
WHY DO THEY BELIEVE THAT?
AND THE ANSWER IS OUR MEDIA.
OUR MEDIA HAS POLLUTED THE
AMERICAN MEDIA SPACE FOR TOO
LONG.
THEY TOLD PEOPLE POLICE ARE
RANDOMLY HUNTING DOWN BLACK MEN
AND ASAT SINATING THEM MIDDAY.
POLICE ARE PUBLIC ENEMY NUMBER
ONE WE BETTER DAMN GET RID OF
THEM.
NOW WHAT IS HAPPENING?
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
>> Lawrence: LISTEN FROM THIS
FROM CARMEN BEST A FORMER POLICE
CHIEF BACK IN SEATTLE, TAKE A
LISTEN TO.
THIS I WOULD READ STORIES ABOUT
THE PEACEFUL PROTEST.
PART OF IT WAS PEACEFUL.
BUT I WAS STANDING LIKE 20 FEET
AWAY FROM A HELL A LOT.
AND I WAS LOOKING -- HAIL DOWN
FEET BEHIND ME I WAS BEHIND A
TELEPHONE POLE.
ONCE ROCKS AND BOTTLES, I HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY AS A CHIEF TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE PROTECTED.
YOU CAN'T GO OUT THERE WHEN
ROCKS ARE BEING THROWN.
>> DAN, THIS IS WHAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT WHEN IT CONCERNS
THE MEDIA.
THE QUESTION I HAVE IS CARMEN
BEST ADVOCATE.
SHE WORKED WITH THE COMMUNITY.
SHE REALLY WANTED TO HELP BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER.
AND EVEN SOMEONE LIKE HER WAS
LAMBASTED.
THEY ESSENTIALLY CUT HER SALARY.
>> THAT'S WHY SHE IS THE FORMER
POLICE CHIEF SHE TOLD THE TRUTH.
THERE IS A COMMON THREAD WITH
ALL OF THE STORIES, AGAIN, IT'S
THE MEDIA.
HOW IS IT THAT SEATTLE HAD AN
INSURRECTION IN THE MIDDLE -- A
LITERAL INSURRECTION PEOPLE SAID
NO.
THIS IS OUR TERRITORY.
GAVE THE DOUBLE-BARRELED MIDDLE
FINGER TO THE CITY OF SEATTLE WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE THIS OVER.
PEOPLE WERE THROWING ROCKS.
PEOPLE WERE BEING ASSAULTED.
CRIMES WERE HAPPENING IN THIS
INDEPENDENT INSURRECTION AREA.
THEY JUST RANDOMLY DECLARED AND
NO ONE IN AMERICA REALLY THOUGHT
IT WAS A BIG DEAL.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE MEDIA TOLD YOU IT
WASN'T A BIG DEAL BECAUSE IT'S A
LIBERAL CITY.
LAWRENCE, I ASSURE YOU IF THAT
WAS THE MIDDLE OF STUART,
FLORIDA, WHERE I LIVE WHICH IS A
RELATIVELY CONSERVATIVE AREA AND
IT WAS A BUNCH OF MAGA SIGN
WEARING PEOPLE WHO TOOK OVER A
PORTION OF STUART, IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN ON THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
"NEW YORK TIMES."
BUT THE MEDIA IS DESTROYING THE
COUNTRY AND THEY ARE DOING IT
DELIBERATELY.
>> Lawrence: DAN, I NEED YOU TO
LEVEL WITH ME.
I MET YOU WHEN I WAS A YOUNG
LIBERTARIAN BACK AT FREEDOM
WORKS.
YOU HAVE ALWAYS BEEN SUPPORTIVE
OF ME.
WE HAVE HAD PASSIONATE.
>> YOU ARE THE MAN.
>> Lawrence: THANKS, BROTHER, I
APPRECIATE IT WHAT DO YOU THINK
IT'S GOING TO TAKE?
YOU HAVE BEEN A COP.
HAVE YOU HAD RESPECT FROM PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE A BROTHER
WHEN I FIRST MET YOU.
HOW DO WE BRING THE FOLKS
TOGETHER?
>> YEAH.
WELL, LISTEN, WE DID IT.
I MEAN, I LIVED THROUGH IT WITH
THE BROKEN WINDOWS POLICING ERA
WITH RUDY GIULIANI IN NEW YORK
CITY.
YOU KNOW, WE ESTABLISHED -- THEY
HAD A CIVILIAN COMPLAINT REVIEW
BOARD.
LISTEN, POLICE NEED OVERSIGHT
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE.
NO GOOD COP IS GOING TO SAY
OTHERWISE.
BUT, ALSO, YOU HAVE TO ENFORCE
THE LAW.
LAWRENCE, I WORKED IN THE 7-5
PRECINCT.
MOST DANGEROUS PRECINCT IN THE
CITY.
IT WAS LARGELY MINORITY
PRECINCT.
OVERWHELMINGLY MINORITY.
PEOPLE USED TO COME TOUT ME ALL
THE TIME.
AND SAY HEY, THIS GUY ON THE
CORNER, IS HE SLINGING DOPE OR
WHATEVER.
PLEASE DON'T TELL HIM I SAID
ANYTHING.
PLEASE, PLEASE, I NEED YOU TO
DO.
HE WOULD BEG AND I WOULD FEEL SO
BAD BECAUSE I WOULD SAY TO
MYSELF.
YOU KNOW, THIS PLACE IS RAVAGED
WITH CRIME AND 90% OF THIS
PRECINCT IS FULL OF GOOD PEOPLE
HAVING THEIR LIVES TORN APART BY
ANIMALS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
STREET.
AND THEY WANT THIS CLEANED UP.
SO HOW DO YOU DO IT?
YOU HAVE TO HAVE GOOD GOOD
POLICE OVERSIGHT.
OBVIOUSLY NO GOOD COP WILL TELL
YOU OTHERWISE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE EFFECTIVE
POLICING WHERE THEY ENFORCE THE
LAW.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT YOU HAVE
CHAOS.
THIN CRUST ON A VOLCANO.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT THIN CRUST
IS MADE OF.
POLICE OFFICERS AND OUR
MILITARY.
THEY ARE THROUGHOUT ENFORCING
THE LAW AND INTERNATIONAL ORDER.
THAT'S IT.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
LORD OF THE FLIES?
YOU WANT PIGGY GET THROWN ONE A
PIG ON THE STICK?
THAT'S WHAT YOU WILL HAVE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WILL HAVE IF YOU
KEEP ATTACKING THE POLICE.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT LIBERALS
AND THEIR MEDIA ALLIES WANTED
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING RIGHT NOW.
WITH A, WHAT, 800 PERCENT
INCREASE IN CRIME IN HOMICIDES
IN PORTLAND?
144% INCREASE IN L.A.?
LAWRENCE, THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE
DYING.
THIS ISN'T A JOKE.
IT'S NOT A TALKING POINT.
IT'S NOT A FOX NEWS KYRON
TALKING POINT.
THESE ARE REAL BODY BAGS.
IN THE REAL WORLD.
BECAUSE REALLY STUPID PEOPLE ARE
MAKING REALLY DUMB DECISIONS.
ONE MORE THING, MINNEAPOLIS,
AFTER THE GEORGE FLOYD INCIDENT,
19 CHILDREN SINCE THEN.
CHILDREN SHOT, KIDS, KIDS,
BECAUSE THE COPS ARE BEING
ATTACKED OVER THERE INSTEAD OF
HANDLING THE REAL PROBLEM THAT
INCIDENT OF POLICE MISCONDUCT.